today we're gonna talk about the best
buys under $50 to make your life in law
school just a little bit better this is
a companion video to the expensive nice
to have but not necessarily necessary
purchases in law school these are the
things that really punch above their
weight you can get for pennies on the
dollar so stick around and learn how you
can make your life in law school just a
little bit better okay so the first
cheap product that I would recommend is
this humble book stand it weighs only
about an ounce it folds up you can put
it in your backpack you can carry it
around you can travel with it almost
anywhere and the reason is because you
can't avoid reading your case book even
if you use our methods and limit the
amount of case book reading you're going
to do you're still going to have to read
out of your case book every once in a
while and that's okay but because you're
gonna be spending so much time reading
out of a huge heavy case book this
little foldable book stand is invaluable
the way it works is you just unfold it
you take your case book you slide it in
and then you expand it out a little bit
which is hard to do while I'm actually
carrying the thing but you sort of get
the idea that you can put it on your
desk read out of the book while working
on a laptop or iPad or or taking notes
and then you don't have to Crane your
neck while looking at the book while
it's vertical it's at a 45 degree angle
and you can take it anywhere you can
take it to the library you can take it
into a friend's apartment when you're
studying together you can do just about
anything and for $15 on Amazon I
wouldn't go anywhere in law school
without this thing you'll use it for
hours it's really cheap I've seen a
bunch of law students on YouTube talking
about this thing I used it when I went
to law school and I'd recommend anyone
who is either going to law school or in
law school get one of these things and
save your back by the way you can find
links to all of these products in the
description below so I recommend getting
one of these little book stands it'll
help save your neck it'll help save your
back and we'll just make reading your
case book just a
little bit more pleasant which when
you're reading these cases anything you
can do to make your life a little bit
more pleasant is probably worthwhile so
the next thing I recommend is getting
either a whiteboard and dry erase
markers or some butcher paper you need
something to help diagram the law itself
the law is complicated and when you get
to an issue spotting hypothetical it
sort of flows like a decision tree you
have the causes of action the elements
under the causes of action the
definition of the elements sub elements
and you need to see how that all flows
together and diagramming usually on a
wall with markers really helps to
understand how things fit together I
think everyone's familiar with a dry
erase board or you could even use a
chalk board but I prefer butcher paper
butcher paper is great because you can
use any marker and save on expensive
whiteboard dry erase markers the best
part is though you can save it for later
one roll can last your entire semester
you can also just buy a bunch of dry
erase markers and right on the window a
beautiful mine style as long as you're
willing to look like an insane person
while you are writing on the window with
dry erase markers of course I've done
crazier things to save money in law
school so I wouldn't blame you okay the
next thing I'd recommend in law school
are some earplugs no I think everyone's
familiar with these little foam things
you put in your ear but ear plugs have a
couple of advantages in law school in
particular that might not be obvious on
first glance in law school a big problem
that almost everyone has is getting
enough sleep ear plugs can really help
when your neighbor decides to hold an
impromptu band rehearsal at midnight or
if your roommates have a very different
sleep pattern than you or if you just
live on a busy street ear plugs if you
use them consistently can help you
create a consistent sleep pattern that
isn't interrupted if there happens to be
stuff going on that particular night it
takes some time to get used to them so I
would recommend using them even when
there aren't loud noises going on
times of an emergency I would just get
in the habit of using them so you can
get good sleep every night
also my earplugs can help you create
consistency in your practice tests now
we have a number of videos to talk about
how practice tests are one of the most
important things you can do to increase
your chances of getting a better grade
in law school and just see the link down
below but one of the problems of doing
practice tests at home is that it is
very different from taking an exam in
class when you take a law school exam in
class during the finals
the sound of clacking keyboards is
absolutely deafening and then there are
other people that will be coughing
they'll be rustling bags they'll be
getting in their backpacks all of these
noises and sounds will not be present
when you are taking your practice test
you're probably taking your practice
tests at home under ideal conditions
which is fine but you don't want to get
used to taking practice tests under
absolutely ideal conditions if you go
into the final with earplugs though you
reduce some of that sound and it is more
similar to the way that you practice
tests at home and as sort of a Pavlovian
response you can associate earplugs with
going into test mode the second that you
put earplugs into your ears your mind
will think okay this is test time now
it's time to pull out all the stops and
you'll be in the mental state necessary
to crush the exam the next cheap thing
that I would recommend in law school is
a physical calendar not a digital
calendar like in Outlook or in Gmail but
an actual paper physical calendar these
things are invaluable there is not as
much time in your semester as it first
appears and what starts out is 8 to 10
weeks it seems like an eternity but that
will go by so fast and you need to be
able to see where you are in time how
much time is left so that you can make
sure that you finish your outline you
can make sure you start doing practice
tests as early as possible and that you
are ready by the time that finals come
around and a fiscal calendar helps you
see it
where you are are you falling behind and
chances are yes and the sooner that you
realize that you simply don't have time
to do these insane multi-page
rambo-style case briefs the better you
need to jettison that as quickly as
possible because there just isn't enough
time in the semester to do all of that
unnecessary work and a physical calendar
will show you where you are in time and
help you plan everything out better to
do it sooner rather than later getting a
physical calendar will save so much time
in anguish and really help you plan out
your semester okay so the last
relatively inexpensive product that I
would recommend for law school is an
alarm I know that sounds crazy but get a
separate alarm do not use your phone do
not let your cell phone reside anywhere
near your bed I now I keep my cell phone
outside of my bedroom it used to be that
I would get work emails all throughout
the night and in a Pavlovian response I
would pick up the cell phone interrupt
my sleep and look at the the emails but
the truth is whether you're in a law
practice or if you're in law school the
emails that come in at two o'clock in
the morning are just not that important
they can wait until the next day so what
I recommend and this is a little bit on
the pricey side but you can get cheaper
options is a sunrise alarm these things
are great unlike a traditional alarm
that just has a blaring sound to wake
you up this displays light gradually
coming on like a dimmer like a reverse
dimmer to convince your body that it's
sunrise and that you should get up
gradually as the Sun rises and this
works even when it's pitch-black outside
there are sounds that go along with it
but this is a much less jarring way to
wake yourself up and I am so much more
rested when I wake up with a sunrise
alarm as compared to a blaring sound and
I got a better night's sleep because I
separated my cell phone from the alarm
function there is a great video on
youtube of simon Sinek where he talks
about the dumbest thing
the millennial generation does myself
included it used to be was using their
cell phone as an alarm and being too
cheap to buy a separate physical alarm I
wholeheartedly agree with them just get
some other clock radio if you want to go
the cheap route or if you want to spend
a little bit more money you can get any
number of 32 $100.00 sunrise alarms they
all seem to work pretty well a separate
alarm will allow you to get more sleep
it'll wake you up more gradually you'll
be in a better mood and you will be more
alert for your law school classes
throughout the day
studies show that a lack of sleep
prevents the ability to memorize
internalize information and remember so
just an hour of sleep more per night
alone could put you above your
classmates in law school so law school
is all about creating a competitive
advantage as compared to your classmates
these little things whether it's a
foldable book stand so you save your
neck from neck pain and allow yourself
to study just a little bit longer every
day in the library or a separate
physical alarm to get more sleep at
night and to wake up more alert these
things may not be huge advantages in and
of themselves but they compound over
time and allow you to study a little bit
longer be more alert and just be a
better law student all-around and when
you're graded on a curve as you are in
law school these little things add up
and allow you to get an advantage over
your classmates and that's what legal
eagle is all about if you like this
video please click like and subscribe
you can download our full guide to law
school down below stick around until
next time where we give you even more
tips on how to crush law school here at
legal eagle the next email get an actual
fit
you can even put it down on a desk to
screw them all right
it helps you create a consistent sleep
with off on a busy sleep or the